guten tag herr doktor dollar ich freue
mich sehr dass ich heute dieses
interview mit ihnen führen kann und noch
mal vielen dank für ihre zusage und als
erstes würde ich sie gerne bitten ob sie
sich kurz vorstellen können also vor
allem berufliche einsicht ja mein name
ist jörg müller ich arbeite hier als
wissenschaftlicher mitarbeiter an der
ludwig maximilians universität münchen
im fach philosophie und könnten sie
zuerst etwas über ihre ausbildung
erzählen also wie lange hat die gedauert
wo haben sie studiert und was genau
also ich habe ungefähr fünf jahre
studiert und ich habe in tübingen
angefangen an der universität tübingen
und zwar damals noch im magister
studiengangs gab damals noch keine
bachelor und master man hat dann gleich
auf ungefähr vier bis fünf jahre
studiert
ich habe das aber in münchen in tübingen
nicht ganz fertig studiert sondern ich
bin nach drei jahren nach münchen
gegangen an die ludwig maximilians
universität und habe dort dann nach
einem jahr
mein magister gemacht und philosophie
und das war noch nicht das ende der
ausbildung das dauert sehr lange in der
philosophie mitunter wenn man einen
doktor machen nicht ich hab da noch mal
vier bis fünf jahre ein
promotionsstudium angeschlossen und
nachdem ich das absolviert hat in dieser
zeit habe ich meine doktorarbeit
geschrieben habe ich dann den
doktortitel verliehen bekommen
sehr interessant und welche
anforderungen gab es denn zur ausbildung
im beruf ist also gab es zum beispiel
eine entziehung studiengang philosophie
es gab überhaupt keine anforderung also
man braucht es sogar ich weiß nicht ob
man das latinum braucht das kleine
latino und das ist vielleicht
erforderlich gewesen aber sonst man sich
nichts also dann hätte er sogar mit
einem durchschnitt von 3,9 oder eben
gerade bestandenen abitur das studium
aufnehmen können und ich habe im
internet außerdem gelesen dass sie auch
außerhalb von deutschland sehr aktiv
waren und auch sind und nennen sie dazu
noch kurz etwas erzählen also wie es
ihrem forschungsaufenthalten gekommen
und was genau haben sie da gemacht
ja also während meines studiums im typen
und münchen war ich nicht im ausland da
war ich noch immer in deutschland aber
während meines promotionsstudium es nach
dem magisterabschluss bin ich dann für
einige zeit für ziemlich genau ein jahr
in die usa gegangen und habe dort an
zwei recht guten universitäten weiter
studieren oder forschungsaufenthalt
verbracht er ist kann ich sehr empfehlen
während der promotion wenn man
promovieren möchte da auch während des
studiums schon eine längere zeit
vielleicht für ein halbes jahr oder ein
bisschen märz ausland zu gehen und wie
lange es jetzt schon an der lmu münchen
tätig seit ziemlich genau sechs jahren
bin ich hier tätig als
wissenschaftlicher mitarbeiter erst
während ich noch meine promotion
geschrieben hatte zu ende und dann als
wissenschaftlicher assistent nach der
doktorarbeit und dann ist man ein
habilitand dann schreibt man seine
nächste arbeit nach der doktorarbeit die
habilitation und da bin ich gerade dran
und ich habe auch gelesen dass sie schon
mehrere bücher geschrieben haben richtig
und wie kam es dazu dass sie anfing zu
schreiben war schon immer eine große
leidenschaft von ihnen also ein buch
muss nun auf jeden fall schreiben wenn
man an eine doktorarbeit schreibt in
deutschland muss man dunkle arbeiten
veröffentlichen und kann die auch im
internet veröffentlichen als digitale
datei aber die meisten machen des als
gedrucktes buch so wie wir hier ganz
viele dieser stationen sonstige bücher
im regal haben
und nachdem ich meine doktorarbeit
veröffentlicht hatte hatte ich einfach
so viel lust noch weitere bücher zu
schreiben ich kam immer auf neue ideen
zweifel auf das problem des bösen das
böse die literatur in der philosophie
natürlich aber auch in der theologie der
politik und darüber habe ich dann mein
nächstes buch geschrieben und habe ich
weitere ideen gehabt über andere themen
habe ich noch ein buch geschrieben
manchmal hat man auch tagungen
organisiert und am ende dann zum
tagungsband veröffentlicht mit allen
beiträgen dieser referenten und wie
wählen sie ein thema für ein buch aus
also ist es eher eine spontane
getroffene entscheidung oder man hat
natürlich je nach persönlichkeiten je
nach erfahrung verschiedene interessen
mit dem man das studium herangeht und
meine interessen haben sich damit im
laufe meines studiums immer
weiterentwickelt manchmal bis
interessante person kennengelernt die
mich auf neue gedanken gebracht haben
und häufig passiert mir dass ich in
meinen seminaren die ich an der
universität gebe da auf neue gedanken
komme und so geht 1 aus dem anderen
hervor am ende kommt dann ein buch
heraus und wie war fingen sie an sich
wir so viel zu interessieren und wie
kamen sie genau darauf also ich habe
mich so mit dem alter zwischen 15 und 16
sowie sie jetzt ungefähr sind da haben
mich wieder so viele fragen sehr
interessiert auch fragen nach der
möglichkeit unsere erkenntnis was können
wir alles wissen wo sind die grenzen und
das wissen solche fragen mich sehr
interessiert könnte nicht die ganze welt
eine bloße konstruktion sein könnten wir
nicht von einem täusche thema und
getäuscht werden rené descartes der
verlosung gesagt dass sie kennen
vielleicht den film matrix war zu meiner
zeit total im mode und mehr fix ist ja
auch so illusionen relations' welt als
solche fragen haben mich sehr
beschäftigt und die habe ich dann nicht
mehr losgelassen und dann wollte ich
eben diesen fragen noch weiter auf den
grund gehen habe mich deswegen
philosophie studium entschieden ja finde
ich auch sehr spannend und wollten sie
schon immer als dozent an einer
universität unterrichten
also wenn man eben philosophie als beruf
betreiben möchte die frage ist ja ob das
überhaupt möglich ist
die beste möglichkeit philosophie als
brotberuf sage ich jetzt mal zu
betreiben ist tatsächlich die
universitäre lehre an der universität
als dozentin oder dozent und insofern
kann mir das sehr gut gelegen das machen
zu können
es war doch mein traum ich hab dann
freut mich das sehr dass sie das jetzt
machen können und wie sie wissen bin ich
in der elften klasse am gymnasium und in
welchen schulfächern denken sie müssen
sich besonders gut sein beziehungsweise
interesse dafür haben damit eine
philosophie studium für mich in frage
kommen würde dies eine gute frage also
in der philosophie dreht sich natürlich
sehr viel darüber
darum was zu schreiben also hausarbeiten
zu schreiben einige eigene gedanken zu
entwickeln also ich würde mal sagen
deutsch wäre nicht von nachteil in
deutsch gut sein aber auch in geschichte
gut zu sein wäre es den folgten blick
über die zusammenhänge zu haben wie sich
bestimmte historische epochen ablösen
und was die eigenheiten
wir brauchen sind ein weiteres fach
werden vielleicht noch mathematik weil
meine philosophie manchmal auch ein
bisschen logisch denken muss und
argumente untersuchen muss aber ich
würde sagen deutsch ist vielleicht das
wichtigste fach und ich denke viele
wissen nicht genau was wir mit dem
philosophiestudium studium anfangen
sollen da man sich unter einem
philosophen heute zur heutzutage ja
nicht mehr so viel vorstellen kann
die berufliche laufbahn ist ja auch
nicht zu geraten irgendwie nach einem
medizinstudium weil die mission dritte
terminiert ist das mein arzt wird war
schwierig für sie ein buch nach ihrem
studium zu finden
da hat es relativ leicht also stimmen
vollkommen zu philosophie zu studieren
ist ein risiko in gewisser weise man
weiß nicht wo man am ende landet weil es
neben den philosophen beruf außerhalb
der universitäten ich gibt und ich hatte
großes glück dass ich eben nach meiner
magisterarbeit und nach der doktor aber
daneben eine an der arbeitsstelle an der
universität angeboten bekam aber das ist
immer auch ein bisschen glückssache
und wie schätzen sie ihren beruf
bezüglich aufstieg schaffen ein
universitätsdozent wenn man an der
universität leitet dann ist so eine
karriere ziemlich klar vorprogrammiert
jedenfalls die schritte die man gehen
muss ist man dann vielleicht mal am ende
prof
das ist natürlich nicht sicher aber erst
muss man sein magister abschluss machen
dann seine oder masterabschluss dann die
promotion und dann in den meisten fällen
noch die habilitation also ein weiteres
buch und dann wenn man etwas glück hat
viele bücher geschrieben hat gute
verbindungen natürlich orientiert hat
dann kann am ende wenn man wie gesagt
gekappt die professoren spielen aber das
ist eben nicht garantieren
ja und wissen sie wie die aktuell
arbeitsmarktprognosen ausschauen wenn
man ein philosophiestudium abgelegt also
außerhalb der universität gibt es
durchaus viele möglichkeit als
philosophin und philosoph unterzukommen
muss leben sehr flexibel
also man muss auch mal andere bereiche
reinschnuppern man muss vielleicht ein
bisschen weiter qualifizieren vielleicht
noch mal ein studium oder philosophie
als nebenfach wählen oder vielleicht an
der ausbildung machen
die sprache noch mal werden muss sehr
flexibel sein aber dann denke ich dass
man auch als philosophien und
philosophie guten der freien wirtschaft
unterkommen kann und was sind ihrer
meinung nach die vor und nachteile ihres
berufs ist also der vorteil jetzt
bezogen auf meinen beruf als
wissenschaftlicher mitarbeiter ist die
freiheit die freiheit in forschung und
lehre ich kann unterrichten was ich
möchte also wenn mich jetzt das thema
des bösen interessierte bietet ein
seminar über das böse nämlich ein
seminar über das gute interessiert dann
bin ich das an also ich habe sehr viel
freiheit kann mir meine arbeit ganz frei
einteilen
ich bin eigentlich mein eigener chef das
ist ganz toll ich kann entscheiden
welches thema ich ein neues buch
schreiben möchte einen neuen aufsatz
oder ob ich eine konferenz organisieren
möchte ein thema ob ich wieder ins
ausland gehen möchte ich bin also sehr
flexibel der nachteil ist eben der dass
man immer nur befristet angestellt ist
man ist nur für bestimmte zeit
angestellt und wenn diese zeit
irgendwann rum ist dann muss man schauen
dass man bis dahin etwas bekommen hat
das ist schon ein bisschen auch unter
druck das ist vielleicht macht an und
die bezahlung ist auch nicht so
besonders
das muss man auch sagen verglichen mit
anderen berufen und der freien welt
schaffe jetzt beispiel rechtsanwältin
oder mediziner aber klingt trotzdem
schon mal gut und sehr interessant
natürlich und nach ihrer langjährigen
erfahrung im akademischen bereich haben
sie da vielleicht noch etwas was die
menschen in meinem alter auf den weg
geben wollen
also ich würde empfehlen immer noch den
wagen interesse das studium zu wählen in
sich genau hinein zu hören was hat mich
immer schon interessiert was sind die
fragen die mich bewegen und nach diese
interessen macht
motivation des strom auszurichten also
wenn man hinter diesem fach steht und
ein großteil ismus entwickelt dann kann
man auch durch durststrecken besser
hindurch kommen und bestimmte krisen die
es auch mal geben mag besser überstehen
als wenn man braucht sagen die
emotionale nähe diese begeisterung für
ein thema die einen durch so ein studium
dann bis in den arbeitsmarkt in den
beruf hinein bringt wenn sie wenn sie
noch einmal die wahl hätten denselben
beruflichen weg gehen würde ich durchaus
machen also ich würde wieder philosophie
studieren ich würde vielleicht das
studium bisschen anders ausrichten ich
würde früher ins ausland gehen noch ein
bisschen mehr zusatzqualifikation jetzt
zulegen aber im großen und ganzen bin
ich mit meiner entscheidung philosophie
studiert sagen sie jetzt zufrieden
okay da fahren jetzt alle meine fragen
und vielen dank für nochmal für die
zugesagt für die zeit die für mich immer
sehr gerne vielen dank für die fragen ja
dann auch wieder sein